[Music]
Anglin does not look so different from
Scotland they are sisters
Queen Elizabeth your cousin Mary has
returned to take up her throne in
Scotland the Queen
my dear cousin Elizabeth I hope we might
meet in person because I might embrace
you but ruling side-by-side we must do
so in harmony not through a treaty
drafted by men lesser than ourselves my
dear cousin that pod nations cherished
each other as we would two kingdoms
United how did the world come to this
wise men servicing the whims of women
Mary is our phone we must never bow to
her as we bow before you you'll have the
boldness to doubt my judgment she is
only your queen if I should not produce
it on my plate
do you have a man booth
[Music]
with heavens blessings we bring an heir
to Scotland and to England
it is a clear provocation we must make
war in Scotland so put your skills to
use
do not play into their hands our hatred
is precisely what they hope for I know
your heart has more within it than the
men who can't with all you you would do
well to watch or work I will not be
scolded by my inferior your period
are you afraid Henry no good because our
swords are not just for sure
we have a scourge upon our line
there's a woman with a crowd
your beauty bravery now I see there's no
course Envy no gifts will be your
downfall should you murder me remember
you murder your sister and you murder
your queen
[Applause]
[Music]